taseer avec les larmes avec lui
selon martine aubry tous faits donnent
envie à gauche quand tu étais au lazaret
bravant les passes et les jours avec
l'art parle pas de signal un mélange de
jours et le grand public et les autres
le mélange de débrancher ne vois pas du
tout dans mon lit j'ai fait un truc
comme ça mais ne bougeait pas que
c'était ok c'est un test c'est pas ça
rend pas moi je voulais voir c'était un
très beau conte se passe à jouer toutes
ses branches un peu envoi je bois gaujac
la rivière voilà regarde toi repens
latéral voie la plus à gauche moi
j'aurais pu aller les bateaux des ja
combien ago à gauche deux mois avec la
rivière et le jour voilà jusque 16 h
il peut arriver d'hélicoptères
la gauche
pd1
c'est vachement vous reste un peu plus
de punch
résumé en peu de temps si tu veux
arrêter les pages par l'accouchement
bull l'a fait pour 2 1 par pas trop
patron pendant pas ma gauche en tout cas
dans vos patins
la rivière qui passe ne comprend pas sa
gauche à droite de la rivière tout le
temps tu perds beaucoup dans le vert et
le contraste des ces contrats se défaire
du vert clair avec une trace est
vachement pouces
et saisissent esprit je batte bébé aux
médias
on peut plus boire latéral en lumière ah
bon fax ip man latéral que tu peux faire
maximum c'est en joue mais attention au
patin mais
on parlera pas de claquer bafta awards
il faut que tu te considères comme il
est beau aussi là tu le vois là le
baobab là celui qui est au centre de
l'écran e
ben ouais je sais que tout seul chez
ruth petit il n'est pas très grave
c'est incroyable naïveté 26,15 là à
droite du baobab à témara fils ici là
bas dit la droite qui est magnifique en
vingt jours ans j'y vais je recule et je
passe devant la légende l'hiver les
magnifiques édiles qui supplée blanc du
parti va arriver dessus
à l'aller la magnifique par ce jour par
le vigan cpo a pas de répéter sur
l'écran du haut parce que moi la balle
aille dans ce sens tu pousses les
contrats majeurs à la tête le pousse et
je me tire à la rivière sur la rivière
sur le côté et tous ces magnifiques soir
on passe un truc comme ça toi les
enfants
l'aga de la barbe ses parents il pèse de
jeu pas sur quoi pourquoi tu te bases
points assurés par burki
d'accord c'est beau l'amour
par conséquent c'est vrai qu'il fait
bioware va par le crif a pas ce qu'on va
voir le pape a chassé ce public on s'en
va
paquebot france
vous éclater
ok go
il va partir devant
devant à droite c'est très beau de vent
ah oui à klose n'a pas savoir le 1
minute et plus que 3 minutes et 15e
minute à le cas cette fois second
la fille tranquille on arrive dans le
dans les feuilles des arbres à feuilles
de le faire des petits plans de des
armes qui perdent leurs feuilles québec
en arrive là on voit la ville déjà pas
combien de la vie de la toile pendant
cette tactique à l'aéroport
je ne veux pas avec khalid ben fraj lot
de crises à la volée bas